Bien crea una lista de pasos ordenados
que resuelvan la siguiente ecuación,
y si te das cuenta tengo aquí
esta ecuación cuadrática,
entonces lo que quiero que hagas justo ahorita,
es que pauses el vídeo,
e intentes resolver este problema
por ti mismo.
Utiliza cada uno de estos pasos
y ve en qué orden los vas a utilizar,
para que así podamos resolver
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí.
Así que no pierdas tiempo
e intenta resolverlo por ti mismo.
Muy bien, una vez que ya estoy suponiendo que ya lo hiciste por ti mismo,
voy a intentar resolver este mismo problema
y para eso...
¡Ah! Déjame copiar esta misma ecuación de este lado.
Tengo 1/2 ¿Ok?
Que multiplica a "x" más 5,
a "x" más 5,
esto a su vez elevado al cuadrado
y a esto le sumamos 2
¿Ok?
Y esto es exactamente lo mismo.
Es lo que nos dice la ecuación que 42.5
¿Ok? De lujo,
ahora, lo que
queremos es aislar,
es despejar esta parte que dice
"x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado
o visto desde otra forma
no quiero más a este 2,
ni a este 1/2,
y bueno si te das cuenta lo que está más alejado
de este "x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado
es este 2, así que para pasar
este 2 del otro lado de la ecuación,
lo que voy a hacer es restar 2
de ambos lados de esta ecuación.
Voy a restar 2 de este lado
pero es que si restó 2 de éste lado de la ecuación,
esta expresión ya no se va a mantener igual.
Fíjate que lo que tengo escrito aquí,
de color verde,
me está diciendo que
estas 2 expresiones son iguales,
si lo que quiero
es que se mantenga la igualdad,
entonces
todo lo que haga del lado izquierdo,
lo voy a tener que hacer
también del lado derecho.
Por lo tanto voy a restar
2 de ambos lados de esta igualdad
y de este lado más 2 menos 2
se van a ir
y solamente me voy a quedar
con esta parte que tengo aquí,
de hecho la voy a poner con este color.
Me voy a quedar con 1/2,
1/2 que multiplica a
"x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado,
y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 42.5 menos 2
lo cual es 40.5
¡de lujo!
¿Ok?
Y bueno antes de seguirnos resolviendo
esta ecuación,
como ya resolví el primer paso,
voy a ponerlo justo aquí,
mi primer paso fue restar 2,
de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Así que déjame tomar
un color un poco más obscuro
y está justo aquí,
"Restar 2 de ambos lados"
por lo tanto voy a decir
que este este es mi primer paso,
mi primer paso es restar 2 de ambos lados,
y es más déjenme escribirlo aquí,
mi primer paso es restar 2 de ambos lados...
de ambos lados.
Ok.
Ya tengo mi primer paso,
ahora recuerda que lo que queremos despejar
es esta parte de aquí,
antes de despejar la "x"
y por lo tanto me estorba este 1/2,
para quitar este 1/2
que te parece si multiplicamos todo,
tanto el lado izquierdo como el lado derecho,
por 2
voy a multiplicar esta parte por 2
y voy a multiplicar esta parte también por 2,
de tal manera que 2 por 1/2,
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 1,
2 entre 2 se va,
1 entre 1 se va
y solamente me quedo con
"x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado
que es justo lo que quería,
"x" más 5
elevado al cuadrado
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que
40.5 por 2
y 40.5 por 2 es lo mismo que 80 más 1,
81, ok.
"x" más 5 elevado al cuadrado,
es lo mismo que 81,
por lo tanto ya tengo mi segundo paso
para resolver esta ecuación,
que fue multiplicar por 2 de ambos lados.
Este es mi segundo paso y lo voy a escribir aquí.
Lo que hice fue multiplicar...
multiplicar...
por 2,
por 2 de ambos lados,
de ambos...
ambos lados
Ok.
Ahora,
vamos a hacer el tercer paso
Ahora quiero que te des cuenta
que tenemos algo elevado al cuadrado,
es lo mismo que 81
por lo tanto estoy diciendo que esta parte
"x" más 5
es exactamente igual
a la raíz positiva y negativa de 81,
por lo tanto,
lo que voy a hacer a continuación
es sacar la raíz cuadrada
de ambos lados de esta igualdad ,
y me va a quedar que "x" más 5,
que "x" más 5 es exactamente lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada,
pero,
recuerda que tenemos 2 raíces,
una positiva y una negativa.
La raíz cuadrada
positiva y negativa de 81...
de 81
y bueno por lo tanto
ya hicimos un tercer paso que fue
sacar raíz cuadrada,
y para eso.
déjame ponerlo con este color.
Lo que hice fue tomar la raíz cuadrada
de ambos lados,
tomar la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados.
Lo voy a poner aquí.
Tomar...
tomar raíz cuadrada...
raíz..
raíz cuadrada
Ok
Y ahora voy a reescribir esta ecuación,
para que nos quede algo más ordenado, e
s decir esto nos quedaría que
"x" más 5, es lo mismo que más -9,
que más -9
¡De lujo!
Ahora lo que quiero despejar aquí es a "x"
y ya casi acabamos,
si te das cuenta
lo único que me hace falta
es quitar este 5,
y para quitar este 5,
lo que voy a hacer,
es restar 5
de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Recuerda que tengo que hacerlo
de ambos lados
para que la ecuación se mantenga
y por lo tanto,
lo voy a hacer de este lado,
y también lo voy a hacer de este lado.
Ok.
De tal manera que de este lado
este 5 y este - 5 se van a ir
y solamente me voy a quedar con "x",
"x" es exactamente lo mismo que
más -9 menos 5
y bueno,
eso lo puedo escribir como -5,
- 5 más -9...
más -9...
Ya con esto de aquí
podríamos despejar a "x".
¡Ah! Pero no nos piden despejar a "x",
lo que nos piden son los pasos,
por lo tanto
vamos a escribir
que aquí me falta el cuarto paso,
que era...
restar 5 de ambos lados.
Este fue mi cuarto paso,
que fue restar 5 de ambos lados
y lo voy a escribir aquí.
Restar.... restar 5...
5...
de ambos lados,
de ambos lados...
lados.
Y ahora ya tenemos aquí los 4 pasos
y solamente por diversión
vamos a encontrar los valores de "x".
Para encontrar los valores de "x"
bueno, pues yo puedo decir que
"x" es igual a -5 más 9,
-5 más 9 es 4
o en su dado caso
"x" es lo mismo que a -5 menos 9
- 5 menos 9 es -14...
-14
y ya está,
ya tenemos los dos valores de "x",
los cuales,
si los ponemos justo aquí.
Vamos a llegar al resultado de 42.5,
por ejemplo
4 más 5 es 9,
9 al cuadrado es 81
81 por 1/2, bueno,
pues eso es lo mismo que
40.5
y si a eso le sumamos 2
me va a dar 42.5.
Y de igual manera para el -14,
pero bueno recuerda que a nosotros nos pedían
los pasos y ya los tenemos aquí.
El primer paso es
restar 2 de ambos lados,
el segundo paso es
multiplicar por 2 de ambos lados,
el tercer paso
es tomar la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados,
y el cuarto y último paso
es restar 5 de ambos lados.
Si nosotros empezamos con esta ecuación
y seguimos
estos pasos en este mismo orden,
vamos a llegar a la solución
de esta ecuación,
y bueno,
aquí ya tenemos nuestros 4 pasos
por lo tanto ya tenemos
resuelto este ejercicio.